-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night".
Thank you so much
for being with us tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
Saturday was President Biden's
79th birthday.
Democrats call it
a happy occasion.
And Republicans call it
proof that inflation
is out of control.
In a new interview,
Michigan Congresswoman
Rashida Tlaib
referred to Democratic Senators
Joe Manchin and Kyrsten Sinema
as, quote, "corporate
Democrats." They're offended,
but just about
the Democrat part.
President Biden is set to speak
tomorrow
about his administration's
efforts to combat rising costs.
So make sure to catch the speech
tomorrow
for just $69.95 on pay per view.
And the FBI reportedly searched
the site of a former landfill
In New Jersey last month,
looking for the body
of union leader Jimmy Hoffa.
So far no Hoffa.
Three Jimmys,
but no Hoffa.
According to a new report,
U.S. domestic air travel
has almost completely recovered
from the pandemic,
Not yet recovered?
Flight attendants.
After Kyle Rittenhouse
was found not guilty,
Republican Congressman
Madison Cawthorn,
Matt Gaetz,
and Paul Gosar
each offered Rittenhouse
an internship, which is great.
It's not jail time,
but it would be nice
if he got
some kind of punishment.
The clothing brand Old Navy
on Friday
launched a virtual
Santa Boot Camp
to train mall Santas
on how to deal
with outrageous
gift requests,
like gas.
And finally, Apple announced
last week
it'll launch a new
self-service repair program
that will offer users tools
and parts
to fix their own devices.
Alright, but Trader Joe's
already does that.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.